Can proto puddy protect an iPhone 7 from a 100-foot drop?
Let's check it out guys, I'm here with Brandon from Gizmo Slip.
I do all kinds of videos: creative
durability tests on the latest tech
products, from dropping stuff off
of buildings inside of homemade cases to
weapon testing, all that good stuff. Since
I made my proto puddy video a lot of you
reached out asking if you can turn a
proto putty into a cell phone case, so we
thought this might be a good opportunity
to see if we could make a cell phone
case that was durable enough to survive a 100-foot drop.
Yes...
Ooh, shiny.
I know.
Brand new iphone 7 never been used. No fingerprints on
it yet but the way the glass looks it's
just so awesome! I'm gonna marr that up with
finger prints inside all right now I'm
not going to show you how to make proto
putty in this tutorial you can go back
and see how to make it step by step in
another video we're going to throw this
together really quick for you there
won't be a lot of time to talk because
we're going out of 5 to 10 minutes or
time we're going to throw this together
and then show you the finished result
I think what we're going to do is take
these two different colors and rip off
chunks of them and then meld them
together so we can get kind of a
multicolored effect and then just take
our iPhone 7 and push it right
down in the middle. That's going to
work the best. I like the finger look here we
go *shoop* Nice, that looks good. Alright
cool now we just have to give that five
to ten minutes to set and we should be in
business. Alright guys time for the
reveal let's see what we got. Now this thing
is stuck solid to my workbench but it
should be rubbery, it should be able to peel up
so Bran is going to work a little saw
blade under there there's going to pull
up gently oh there we go check it out
all right actually the rest of that just
popped off no problem. Handmade iPhone 7
case! nice pun now for all the porn
stars we're just going to run that
underwater a little bit and clean it up
and see what our final product looks
like alright guys so update we have
arrived at a random parking lot we got
our proto putty case which is extremely
flexible extremely bendy it's got a cool
marble texture to it got the blue and
the purple which melded together really
well so originally when we had the the
phone in there there was not enough
putty in front of the phone we were
worried it might pop out so we add
another layer of blue putty and meld it
really well it looks like it was part of
the original case except for the color
so I think the chances of survival have
gone from about twenty percent to maybe
45 how do you think well I think
probably seventy percent chance to
survive all this thing's looking really
good so here's the contraption we got
set up we're just using a piece of
paracord dangling from the underside of
this inspire one there's a 2 loop system
where we use a loop on the phone and a
loop on the drone the only thing holding
these together is this fuse cord so by
the time this burns through the loops
will disconnect and drop our phone down
to the ground we are all set up cameras
ready to go drones ready to fly so it's
action time. It's action time!
alright check it out, drone's in the air
got my propane torch let's light this
thing off
the phone has impacted and I think
probably in the worst way possible
pretty I saw that hit face down so let's
go check the Phantom and then check if
the phone survived. We got high speed
footage right over here come check this out
guys so this is a Phantom v1611 I film
all my videos with it now we're
recording at five thousand frames per
second okay so so we got this little bit
of fuse that drops out over here and
there an impact see it comes down hits
the left side oh wow and that proto putty is
wigglin' like crazy it looks like a giant
water bed that's like "bloop bloop bloop" and it
bounced like freakin three or four feet
in the air oh dude that went way higher than I thought
yeah out of the shot even. Yeah, and then
the follow-up impact here oh yeah it's
almost like a whole other drop test yeah
it is so maybe so let's go find out
we're going to check out the damage
let's go check it out okay so this thing
bounced out of the proto putty and then
landed over here question I guess for
this is did it survive so it's face down
right now it's damaged right here
damaged right here and it's still going
it still recording that means we got the
footage guys what's up nice to see you
oh I'm seeing some twists some been oh
yeah I see that too yeah okay when it
impacted here you know that probably was
like a whole 'nother 15-foot drop after
it bounced out of that case huh huh that is really
impressive so when the phone came down
impacted with this side and that's where
we had the reinforcements but this side
wasn't reinforced to the phone popped
out and it was almost like a springboard
wasn't it flipping through the air yeah
about 15 feet high and we got a whole
nother drop test out of it but can't
believe it survived the second drop
that's actually pretty impressive which
uh well definitely bent it but this is
still a functional phone still usable
really still recording huge shout out to
Brandon from Gizmo Slip for making the
trip up here and making this video
possible guys this is so much fun glad I
could be here experiencing your lab it's
pretty awesome I'm super stoked that we
got to do this experiment first of all
and then to drop it from a drone
the epic as well. Brandon's going to have a
lot more content with epic slow-mo so
make sure you head over to Gizmo Slip
give them a subscribe and look for the
things that he puts out in the future
and thank you guys for joining us for
this experiment we looking for in the
next video talk to you then :)